The shorter leg is 12, the longer leg is 16, and the hypotenuse is 20. Great
problem solving if you found those numbers. Our setup will be very similar to
the problems before. We'll have the hypotenuse of 4x, and legs of 3x plus 1,
and 2x plus 2. We square the first leg to get 9x squared, plus 6x plus 1. We
square the second leg to get 4x squared plus 8x plus 4 and we square the
hypotenuse to get 16x squared. Next we'll combine the like terms of x squared,
the like terms for x and the constant terms to get this left hand expression.
13x squared plus 14x plus 5. Now we want to move all of these terms to the
right hand side of the equation by subtracting them. We subtract each of these,
so that way we can get an x squared term that's positive and we can get 0 on
the left hand side. Next we'll use factoring by grouping, to get the factors of
3x plus 1, times x minus 5. We set this factor equal to 0. And we set this
factor equal to 0. Solving for x, we'll have x can equal negative one third, or
x can equal positive 5. Now, we won't let x equal negative one third since this
side length will end up being negative four thirds. That wouldn't make sense.
Instead, we'll let x equal 5, and we'll substitute it in for each of these
expressions. This is how we get the shortest leg to be 12, the longer leg to be
16, and the hypoteneuse to be 20.